I am will and this is Tabata Tabata is
an high-intensity interval training
protocol that a professor in Japan came
up with in 1996 he created this 20
seconds of work 10 seconds of rest over
eight rounds what I can incorporate
anything across the board you can do
with push that about of burpees Tabata
situps
well cross the design is they've taken
the Tabata a timing protocol and taking
it into their bag of tricks Oh what do
we have we have four minutes what can we
do where can we increase this athletes
aerobic activity and actually it will
increase your anaerobic activity as well
because we'll throw in weighted
activities this is your at-home two
bottom full body workout hey guys so we
are here with the Tabata full body
workouts now the things about full body
workouts is it's one of those things
that you can jump right into early in
the morning to get your day started
properly or you know the end of the day
to de-stress so right now we're gonna
take a look at some examples of a full
body workout
Tabata style we've got two moves today
one with a plate one with just your body
the first work what we call ground to
overhead okay it's exactly what it
sounds like you're taking the plate from
the ground and putting it up over your
head
pick it up with your chest up setting
your back setting your hips down and
back so then it's a safe pull off the
ground you wanted to grab the plate with
a firm grip deep breath in
you're just gonna launch it up over your
head so you're using all that momentum
in your hips to stand up with it I'm
gonna bring it down close to you so you
don't want to swing it out it's not like
a kettlebell swing it's literally up and
push okay so you keep it close to your
body there so do that for 20 seconds the
next thing is the AB mat setup we use
the AB mat if you look it's curved like
your spine it gives your spine something
something to push into to embrace the
natural curve of your spine so now if
you don't have said apparatus you can
use a towel a pillow something like that
I'm assuming oh absolutely
fold the towel in half put it under your
back a small pillow works just anything
to support that natural curve that you
have down in your lower back
ready get started let's do this
so full squat you want to make make sure
your weights on your heels chest up good
and we'll start for 20 seconds in three
two one go head good even higher up
really extend up top there we go three
good before really use your hips to
drive it up in three two one
rest two one so you want to touch back
behind your head and then touch your
toes you're gonna get that full range
feel free to use your arms good nice
range of motion there three two one rest
for 10 seconds
and 3 2 1 10 seconds arrests in 3 2 1 go
try to make an active return down so
really slam your body back there you go
2 1 awesome man that's pretty good so to
recap we are starting off with 20
seconds to ground to overhead lift all
by 10 seconds arrest 20 seconds of the
AB mat sit-ups if you don't have the mat
again you can use a towel followed by
ten seconds to rest you repeat that four
times that gives you your total body
tabata workout good stuff man
really fun feel like a superhero now you
are subscribe so you don't miss out on
any other fighting weight episodes